le télétravail une certaine manière va
renforcer les inégalités puisque
finalement selon que l'on est au début
de sa carrière d'ailleurs les y
renforcer les inégalités
intergénérationnelles parce que pour moi
la catégorie de population qui va le
plus souffrir du télétravail ce sont les
jeunes il ya les femmes bien sûr on en a
je pense pas mal parlé sur sur d'autres
médias j'ai vu beaucoup d'articles aussi
sur ce sujet donc les femmes pourquoi
parce que elles vont cumuler télétravail
chez elle est évidemment travail
domestique dont elles sont encore
aujourd'hui et malgré les progrès
réalisés par les hommes le plus en
charge de ces tâches la donc elle
multiplie les tâches de chez elle
si les enfants meilleurs résultats à
l'école à mon avis c'est en grande
partie grâce aux femmes plus qu'aux
hommes
mais par ailleurs les jeunes donc qui
débute dans leur vie professionnelle qui
n'ont pas encore d'expérience à qui on
n'a pas encore transmis des savoir faire
qui vivent dans des petits dans des
petits espaces parce qu'ils n'ont pas
encore des salaires qui leur permettent
de se payer de plus grands espaces ces
jeunes sont ceux qui vont le plus
souffrir de ces conditions de travail il
souffrait déjà de la crise écologique
dont il a hérité de leurs parents et
bien maintenant on va leur donner ces
nouvelles modalités de travail qui vont
appauvrir leur expérience appauvrir leur
vie quotidienne parce que travailler
dans des mauvaises conditions
c'est tout à fait un confortable et tout
à fait
désagréable qui vont limiter aussi leurs
perspectives de carrière parce que
comment repérer un jeune talent
uniquement parce qu'il produit dans la
vie de bureau normal on repère quelqu'un
aussi à sa manière de se comporter à sa
manière de parler aux relations qu'il
noue avec les uns et les autres il ya un
jugement qui est beaucoup plus précis
beaucoup plus fin que le jugement
arbitraire qui va être fait sur un
travail qui consiste à quoi envoyer note
envoyée à une présentation powerpoint un
fichier excel voyez tout cela appauvrit
considérablement y compris la
reconnaissance que l'on peut donner aux
travailleurs et les jeunes en pâtiront
en premier lieu
[Musique]